[Applause]
[Music]
Des why don't you come to your
senses you've been out riding
fences for so long now oh you're a hard
one but I know that you've got your
reasons these things that are pleasing
you can hurt you
somehow don't you try the Queen of
Diamonds Bo she'll beat you if she's
able you know the Queen of Hearts is
always your
best now it seems to me some fine things
have been laid upon your
table but you you only want the ones
that you can't
get
Des
for why don't you come to your
senses come down from your
fces open the
gates it may be right now yeah but
there's a rainbow above you you
let somebody love you let somebody love
you let somebody love
you before it's
[Music]
too
[Applause]
[Music]
late
[Applause]
thank you guys y'all have a great night
I'm going
home